hello everyone and welcome to a really
insane game from round four of the 2019
check uh mild men a Swiss tournament
it's a Vladislav kovalev biller was a
grand master who in January if you
remember won the Tata Steel challengers
tournament gaining the right to joined
the top a student master tournament next
year so that's gonna be yeah it's gonna
be very exciting and well he's just
overall a very strong grandmaster I
think rated around twenty six sixty one
so still to 200 rating points low rated
the Magnus but like we say I mean who
isn't so that being said let's check out
this game
yeah it's I'll just have to show it to
you it tell you what I mean so II for by
by kovalev and Carson of course goes for
his Sicilian c5 we have nice to have 3
d6 and now Bishop to b5 check the canal
attack Bishop to d7 by Magnus blocking
track and now Bishop captures on d7 with
Queen captures on b7 and now c4 so
gaining a firm grip on the d5 square
black will not be pushing d5 anytime
soon and well you left something behind
the d3 square so Carlsen makes an
outpost on d4 for himself which is
pretty usual stuff if you don't go for
the open Sicilian Knights the sea 3 by
Kovalev Knight to c6 by Carlsen ends now
d3 with Bishop to e7 by Carlsen a3 and
now Bishop to d8 this is a maneuver
across and already used in the game
in 2000 and I believe in 2017 in the
Grantchester is a blitz tournament in
Paris where he faced a etienne back row
and Carlson was able to win that game
but this game takes a different turn
here a couple of castles this is the
same as cross an already played against
back row we have Knight G to e7 now that
the e7 Square has been freed for the
night and now b4 and in the in that game
that we mentioned C captures and b4 was
played like I said cross and was able to
win the game but it was a blitz game but
here Carlsen just castles King side and
I will say that this is now a new move
as of move 10 we have a completely new
game even though there
there are a few more moves that I have
found in my new database but they were
played between very weak players so we
will call this a new move unless I find
like a really good reason when I use the
bigger database to mention it I will not
be mentioning it just just giving you a
heads up so B captures on c5 by Kovalev
with D captures on c5 by crossing and
Knight to d5 grabbing the d5 outpost for
his knight and Knight to g6 by Carlsen
with Bishop to e3 developing attacking
the c5 pawn and now b6 just defending
that pawn and knights the d2 by kovalev
and now Carlson takes this opportunity
to play f5 as he did prepare it with he
captures on f5 Queen captures on f5 and
then out comes Knight to e4 the knight
is now nicely maneuvered so here white
has excellent outpost for both of his
knights with Knight to f4 by Carlsen
offering the trade here Bishop for a
knight or a knife for a night but then
Kalevala loses this excellent outpost on
d5 but he finds a different idea a
better idea he just plays g3 and says
okay you can you can just move your
knight back so Carlsen first before
removing the right place Queen to g6
just pinning this pawn here and we have
a king to h1 now asking do you want to
move the knight do you want to capture
on d5 or what do you want to do so here
you could move the Knights to h5
although it's unclear what you're gonna
do here you could go night I try to f6
and then try and trade from there but if
you want to trade you might as well
trade right away so Knight captures on
d5 with C captures on d5 and denounced a
good question what what do you do with
the night here so do you go with the
knight back or or do you play something
else well this is one of those cases
where a move would the knight back is
not the strongest move here here
strongest is Knight to a5 because it
doesn't allow White's to advance his
deep on with tempo but Carlsen goes for
Knights the e7 here and he allows d6 it
seems like it's overreaching that you
will not be able to defend this pawn but
it actually works so call F pushes these
six attack Carlson's nine
we have nice to f5 now with a double
attack here and this is now what Kovalev
plays he plays Queen to b3 with check
now Carson could block with Queen to f7
we would maybe see a queen trait here
but cousin decides to keep everything on
the board he keep he plays King to h8
and now Queen to d5 so this is how
Korolev will protect his pass d6 pawn
and now if cross and can get rid of this
point then that's a very dangerous pass
pawn
we have Bishop the f6 by Carlsen making
room for the rook to join the defense
would rook to b8 and now rook a rook 81
Kovalev brings the other look inside
again we have rook a to d8 and here we
have f4 by Kovalev this is the strongest
move in the position and it's really
it's really hard to decide for Magnus
what to do of course you cannot allow F
captures on e5 then this is just a
winning position for white so what to do
you play here it's very interesting and
I will mention this for a specific
reason
the the Norwegian a supercomputer say
say assess this position is completely
winning for white but you still have to
play the absolute best move so let's see
how the game continued but even though
the game the position is much better for
Koval at the time on the clock is Magnus
an hour and 20 minutes and call of 18
minutes so it's not like Kovalev was so
extremely prepared he really really
calculated everything out so he really
spent at the time and worked out every
possible variation so he played f4 and
after 18 minutes of thinking no sorry
after 22 minutes of thinking about the
position cedar or do you want to capture
first or or do you wanna play something
else first and then capture because you
have to capture this cross on the sides
for Knight captures on e3 we have
chapters on d3 and now as you cannot
allow this yeah e captures on f4 we have
rope captors on a four by Kovalev now
putting a lot of pressure on this bishop
here and if you trade everything and
you're left with this this exponent
that's that's a very good position for a
four : with h6 by Carlsen and now I will
mention this once again a Norwegian
supercomputer says they assessed this
position as like plus plus 16 for white
completely
and here Koval it has to make a move so
what would you play here June or just
just a question feel free to pause the
video and decide on what path you will
choose for those of you who are able to
do it
congratulations on playing perfect moves
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show
Magnus play elsewhere Koval have played
the d7 here and it's a it's a great move
but SSA suggested a night captures on f6
that it's better to trade everything and
then go for these seven for example
Knight captures rook captures now you
push d7 it's just a a very strong pawn
and blacks pieces are very much tied
down for example you can't really go
anywhere with the Queen a lot of rope
captures on f6 to mess up your pawn
structure the King Queen that constantly
has to keep an eye on the ae8 where
otherwise you're gonna get rook to e8 so
it's not easy to make a move for black
King page 7 not allowing any checks
along the back rank but now rook
captures Queen captures and now King to
g2 you just start improving the position
you will bring the rook into the game
double up here just a lot of very very
possible winning radius here so this is
or this is the path that Sesay decides
to go for and that this is now
completely winning for white but Koval
ever decides to go for d7 first also
it's a very nice winning idea but it
allows Carson to avoid so many
simplifications he decides to keep
pieces on the board as well he should
with Bishop to e7 not allowing Knight
captures on f6 we rook eat f3 now
putting pressure on the f8 square if you
allow this trade then d8 will come so
rook captures on f4 and now rook
captures on f4 and now it's 55 minutes
for Carson and 7 minutes for Cola life
and here a Crossin is basically without
the move there is no good move for
Carlsen here so whatever he plays it's
just bad you could waste time with a 6
it is possible or you could play rook to
g8 but you know generally you don't want
to make a move that doesn't improve your
position this is just a nothing mu not
nothing happens here so Carlsen doesn't
have a useful what he does have is that
he is up on time and he tries to use
that as
and he plays b5 so here he asks Colo if
you have seven minutes on the clock
do you want to try and find some sneaky
mood that wins the game on the spot or
do you maybe want to dis juicy c5 pawn
it's a free pawn why not just grab it
and Koval have really really thought a
lot about what to do here and Indian he
decided to capture on c5 and he had like
two minutes two and a half minutes on
the clock when he played Knight captures
on c5 instead a much more sturdy idea
was a rook to f5 with just preparing
Ruby 5 putting pressure along the e file
and also for example if something like
c4 is played then you can just go rook
to e5 and if rook to g8 just wasting a
move then you play King to g2 and again
black has no moves you have to waste a
move Bishop to d8 only now you capture
on c5 and now when this knife comes to
e6 then that is just a real monster
night and it's just game over but with
so little time on the clock go after b5
grab the juicy pawn and we have Bishop
captures on c5 now by Carlsen Queen
captures on c5 and now cousin has to
decide whether it's okay or not to
capture the d3 pawn problem is if you
capture it you get Quint
f8 with check checking the King
attacking the rook and after characters
captures and the king moves king h7 you
will bring a queen into the game and now
you will have to calculate it after
Queen to e4 check in g1 Queen e1 check
King goes here we need to check a little
block with the rook and very quickly
black will run out of checks and you
will be able to win this game as you are
up a whole rook
so across and first decides to decides
to go for King to h7 he hides his king
there and now
Koval it has to decide what to do here
call F plays Queen to d5 it's the
strongest move into position just a nice
centralizing move keeping around this
point keeping an eye on this point he
doesn't want to over grab bonds with
Queen captures on b5 if you if you go
for Queen captures on b5 you still have
to play eight more moves to reach time
control and you don't want to let
crossing of the hook here across and
would play Queen to e6 not allowing the
Queen to retreat to d5 also threatened
just rook captures here and now you have
to calculate the
if rook after sandy 7 then the winning
chances are just gone for example if you
defend it then Queen e1 check will lead
to a draw kingi to Queenie to check if
you try to run king h3 Queen f1 check
King g4 chat Queenie to check and so on
you will definitely have a perpetual so
a couple of decides I don't need anymore
pawns Queen to d5 and now Carson plays
Queen to g5 and here he says okay you
wrap up on do you wanna trade Queens and
you even get to mess up my pawn
structure even further and then we play
the same game Kovalev is not interested
in this and he can play rook to f5 rook
to five is very interesting as it keeps
the queen is on the board and forces
Magnus to fine but with so little time
on the clock lasts less than a minute
for Kovalev you have to figure out what
happens if Queen c1 check what happens
if Queen East 7 followed by Queen e1
check just a lot of a lot of crazy crazy
ideas in the position of where huges
don't have the time to calculate all of
them so here we have Queen to e4 check
and Magnus blocks Queen g6 Queen back to
d5 by koulev Queen to g5 again crossing
offers a trade of Queens and now Queen
to d6 again Luke f5 is the idea but
college without time he repeats the
position a few times to gain his thirty
seconds in increment on the clock but he
quickly burns it Queen to d6 now okay
it's a new position but now Queen to g6
again Carson offers a trade of Queens
Queen to c7 now going after the rook
here and now cross an instantly plays
Queen to g5 guarding his rook and again
forcing kovalev if you want to win find
something else
Koval repeats Queen to d6 and cross and
repeats Queen to g6 and here the
strongest move in the position is Queen
to d5 but if Cole ever goes for Queen to
d5 then after Carlsen riprap or replies
point to g5 it will be threefold
repetition so here Kovalev is unable to
play the strongest move because of the
threefold repetition rule so he has to
play something else he goes Queen back
the c7 and cross and just repeats Queen
to g5 asking what do you want to play
again you cannot repeat Queen to d6
because Queen g6 again now offers a
three-fold repetition this way so Queen
the c6 kovala finds yet another square
for the Queen here
try because he's living on increment so
he is constantly using the 30 seconds
that he gets after playing every move
and this has already moved 39 so he has
to make one more move Crossing place
Queen to e7 now that to the Queen is no
longer occupying this square it is
possible and now Carlson is just
threatening rook captures on b7 so here
Kovalev needs one more move to make time
control he captures the b5 pawn and now
now he gains additional time on the
clock but now cross and just goes for
rook captures and d7 Queen e1 is nothing
the King will just go King G to check
check Lucas blocks and now me you can
just go back winte e6 and threaten to
win the phone this way but if you can
already grabbed the pawn why not just do
it so rook captures on b7 by Magnus and
now you can look at this position on the
board Queen to a5 check who is plate and
then g6 by Magnus asking cover like what
do you want to do now so if you look at
this position on the board which is okay
kovalev is up a pawn but how do you how
do you push for this and if you look at
that position for example maybe I'll
move 29 where Carlsen played this b5 b5
movement over this juicy pawn the
position is completely winning for white
it's just the Kovalev was extremely we
even have a photo of this here we have
it this is this moment where Carlsen
offered the juicy bone and he played b5
you can see that Korolev is really his
brain is working in overtime he had two
cups of coffee as you can see and you
can see that Carson is hiding his eyes
so kobalava doesn't see which pieces
Crossing is looking so it's really just
in a very intense situation but yeah he
didn't find the best continuation due to
severe time trouble he went for the
juicy pawn and well now we're at move 40
after work after Sun d7 Queen f5 check
in g6 where this is the position on the
board Kovalev played Queen to a fate
offer the Queen trade with Queen
captures rook captures and now not going
for the pawn right away and allowing
rook to f7 check and pick up the pawn
cross and pushes the room back and now
rook to e8 with
the f6 Carlson starts improving the
position of the King King to g2 and now
rook captures on d3 with rook captures
on a seven looked the D to check with
King to g1 and it was in this position
that the players agreed to a draw as
even though kovalev has a past a pawn
the rook is too active the king will
never be able to join join the game
you'll just put this row behind a passed
pawn and that's pretty much it easy
drawn Sam Carson almost lost his I
always say winning streak but it's
actually an unbeaten streak so with this
game Carson is now on a 94 game unbeaten
streak so he needs six more to reach
ding and seven more to surpass things a
record of 100 games unbeaten streak
will he be able to do it it's hard to
say because here it's just this is why
most high rated players don't play in
open tournaments because he will face a
weaker opponents and when I say weaker I
mean extremely strong players like
Vladislav Kovalev who is 26 61 but still
he's 200 over 200 rating points lower
rated than Carlsen so if course son
loses the game against such a player he
will lose so much rating that yeah he's
just gonna be hitting himself and if he
has three bedrooms it's just a disaster
he could drop like from 2880 something
to 28 40 or something like that which
would be a shame that's why pretty much
top rated players do not play in Swiss
tournament Swiss tournaments but here we
have a such case that he doesn't mind
and he just came here to have fun
and well all for some juicy points to
his opponent so and it's just insane I'm
sure kovalev is really sad and he's
really beating himself for for letting
letting Magnus off the hook but this is
just what I wanted to say it doesn't
matter what stockfish says doesn't
matter what says he says you are you
know you are playing and you never
expect your opponent it doesn't matter
what the position is if you're if the
assessment is maybe - -20 - 30 your
opponent is not you know underworld
Network a supercomputer or a really
strong engine
he will make human moves he will make
mistakes and it always helps if you're
the world champ
and you know people get really nervous
like like here but yeah I really an
insane game everyone thought that Magnus
was going down here but in the end he
survived and he continues his well this
is his third draw drawn game in this
tournament so drawing three but also his
unbeaten streak so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Gabrielle philippic and further
nestin for a contribution to my channel
thank you what I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see soon continuing the coverage
of the isle of man chess tournament
checking up in your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the world so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day